this growth in wealth inequality it is
going to keep the middle class and the
workingclass poor it's going to cut
government services and that is the
people in this room their kids their
grandkids will OB we are not dealing
with wealth inequality you well you
rightly said you spent a lot of time
thinking about
this what do you what do you think the
solution or Solutions might be we have
to shift the tax system we have a tax
system which taxes ordinary working
people 30 40 50 60% while people like
the Duke of Westminster can inherit 10
billion and nothing if you do that
wealth will be sucked out of the middle
class it's already been completely
bankrupted the working class it will
bankrupt the government which is what we
are
seeing and there'll be poverty there'll
be broad poverty there will be no middle
class left why are we taxing working
people more than billionaires tax wealth
not work give these people a break give
their kids a chance tax the billionaires
of course you should